el expresidente en su Laberinto
Donald Trump podría enfrentar un nuevo
lío judicial en plena precampaña por
volver a la casa blanca se trata de una
investigación que se abre después de que
en enero de 2021 Trump llamara a un
funcionario de Georgia y le pidiera que
encontrara más votos para así dar vuelta
a la derrota electoral que sufrió en ese
estado frente al demócrata Joe biden en
los comicios presidenciales un gran
Jurado Que indaga en esas pesquisas
considera que podría haber testigos que
hayan mentido mientras se encontraban
bajo juramento una mayoría del Gran
Jurado considera que puede haberse
cometido perjurio por uno o más testigos
que testificaron ante él el gran Jurado
recomienda que la fiscal del distrito
busque la respectivas acusaciones
portales crímenes en donde la evidencia
es convincente
el gran Jurado escuchó los testimonios
de unos 75 testigos a lo largo de siete
meses incluyendo el del ex alcalde de
Nueva York Rudy giuliani abogado de
Trump el Antiguo mandatario no fue
citado
ahora es la fiscal del distrito de
Fulton Fany Willis quien lidera esa
investigación la que recibirá las
recomendaciones del Gran Jurado la
interrogante podría la fiscal presentar
cargos criminales contra Trump
por todo lo que sé sobre la evidencia en
Georgia Donald Trump podría enfrentarse
a múltiples cargos de injerencia
electoral así como algunos crímenes no
electorales como dar falso testimonio y
manipulación de Testigos
el informe de Gran Jurado en especifica
Cuáles son los testigos de quienes
sospecha mintieron en sus testimonios
ese Delito se paga en Georgia con entre
1 y 10 años de cárcel